[Music]
from director Christopher Nolan who
prompts fanboy boners from whatever he
touches comes a greedy continuation of
Batman and his ongoing battle with
throat cancer
someone knows where he is
yep in a panic Jennifer the dark night
in a city lined with an absurdly
convenient number of school buses
countless a realistic new vision of the
Batman saga that throws away silly bat
nipples for completely unrealistic new
features like the mad car cutter
the bat gun bender the bat-armor that
can withstand Falls from any height but
sucks against bullets n the bat device
that inexplicably turns every Gotham
City cell phone into a portable sonar
reader which downloads an infant amount
of data that's instantly transmitted
wirelessly to Batman's eyes how is that
possible it takes me five minutes to
download Angry Birds a silent guardian
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about racking up
millions of dollars and people's
personal damages the Joker will test
Batman like never before when he places
two hostages at two different locations
which for some reason means that Batman
nor any one call with the Gotham City
Police Department can reach them both at
this same time he filmed bursting with
not-so-subtle foreshadowing you either
die a hero or you live long enough to
see yourself become the villain that'll
help you swallow Harvey's evil
transformation which is completely out
of character it's about what fair a hero
that takes the blame for a fallen savior
for the better of the city
you're not mad at me
wait wait why couldn't they just blame
the Joker for all these deaths he's been
killing people the entire movie
vilifying Batman makes no sense
starring Cabbage Patch face Nurse Jackie
los playas had a monoliths rusty
Griswold and I weren't tryna noticing
that from here on out The Dark Knight
who we kidding this movie is [ __ ]
awesome
tell us what movie you'd like to see as
an honest trailer and leave a comment
with the word you'd like to hear me say
next time in my awesome voice snozzberry
Luke fiddles glockenspiel wobble they
wanted to protect our ice cream but the
freezer refused to listen